I have to confess I came very close to
canceling tonight why is that when I
found out that I was going to be seeing
someone that I have a little bit of
history with and it's one-sided history
it's somebody I had a long-term crush on
because my name is on the show I know
it's not you okay and it's not Andi okay
I was a girl
uh-huh go in still are by the way
[Laughter]
puberty yes my womanhood was awakened
via dream by mr. Steve Martin I pictured
myself making this confession I never
pictured him to be sitting next to me on
the couch because sometimes the guest
leaves yeah I'm not even I'm not even
sure what you mean yeah yeah I'm a
little confused right after dead men
don't wear plaid awesome movie and then
I saw the jerk and that just sealed the
deal right that's a very sexy
you haven't seen it yeah yeah so you
have a dream and then it's a it's an
erotic dream with with mr. Martin in it
yeah Wow that happened yeah and I have
never heard that before
well in my journal yeah
[Applause]
to say yeah well I don't even know how
to move on from that I like my dream
making machine is working perfectly
[Laughter]